اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما كالعاده اليوم كذلك نناقش فيها
محاور جديده من ملف الاتفاقيه السعوديه
الايرانيه وفي نقاطنا ومللفاتنا للنقاش
لهذا المساء
بعد حديث صحيفه
في ظل الاتفاق السعودي الايراني وهل اصبح
مستقبلهم في مهب الريح
الميليشيات في سوريا العراق ولبنان هل
انتهى دورها بعد الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
وكيف ستتعامل معها دولا
وما هي السبلة من الصين ضامن للاتفاق كي
تحافظ على تنفيذه في ظل تهديدات
الميليشيات
اهلا بكم لا يزال صدى الاعلان عن الوصول
الى اتفاق بين السعوديه في ايران وايران
برعايه الصين في العاشر من مارس الماضيه
تردد وسط تصريحاته ومواقف متبادله من
اطراف الاتفاق والمجتمع الدولي حيث نقلت
صحيفه وسطي جونال عن مسؤولون الامريكيين
قوله ان ايران وافقت على وقف شحنات
الاسلحه السريه الى ميليشيا الحوثي في
اليمن بموجب اتفاقها مع السعوديه على
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين
واعتبر المسؤول الذي لم تذكر الصحيفه اسمه
ان هذه الخطوه من شانها المساهمه في
التوصل الى اتفاق لانهاء الصراع الدائر في
اليمن منذ عام 2014 بشكل نهائي وقال ان
هذا الاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه يعطي دفعه لاحتمال
التوصل الى صفقه يمنيه لانهاء الحرب في
المستقبل القريب كما اعتبر المسؤول ان
نهجه ايران تجاه الصراع سيكون نوعا من
الاختبار الحقيقي لنجاح الاتفاق
الدبلوماسي الذي توصلت اليه الرياض وظهران
الاسبوع الماضي بواسطه صينيه يذكر ان
طهران نفت علنا عده مرات انها تزود
ميليشيا الحوثي بالاسلحه ولكن مفتشها
الامم المتحده تعقبوا مرارا شحنات اسلحه
مصادره عائده الى ايران
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من مارب العميد
ركن عبدو المتحدث الرسمي باسم القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه اهلا بك من الكويت
الدكتوره سعد بن طفل العجمي وزير الاعلام
الكويتي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من الكويت معك دكتور سعد دكتور
سعد هذه الاتفاقيه بالغه الاهميه تعلم
بانه ستكون لها تبعات والبعض يستذكر
الموضوع اليمني بكل ما يتضمنه هذا الملف
من حساسيات ومن نقاط شائكه هل تعتقد بان
هذه الاتفاقيه قد تتيح بدايه حل للملف
اليمني وكيف
وتصحيح انا لست بالوزير وزير الاعلام انا
وزير الاعلام الاسبق لكن انا طبعا
الحقيقه بانه هذا من الملفات الهامه
والمباشره بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الجرح اليمني النازف هو جرح يمني
خليجي سعودي نازل للمنطقه برمتها وكانت
ايران وحتى الان حريصه على ان يبقى هذا
الجرح نازفا وذلك بتمويله وتاهيله واعداده
وامداده لكافه الاسلحه دعونا نذكر مشاهده
الكريم بانه بموجب القرار اثنين اثنين
واحد سته صادم مجلس الامن في ابريل 2015
لا احد يعترف به حكومه الحوثي وسيطرتها
بانقلابها في سبتمبر 2014 على الشرعيه
اليمنيه في صنعاء وفي نفس الوقت ايضا لا
نريد مبسط المسائل يعني دعونا نتذكر ونذكر
ايضا المشاهد الكريم بان الملف اليمني
اعقد من التدخل الايراني او حرب التحالف
لاسقاط هذا الانقلاب واعاده الشرعيه كما
يؤكد ضيفك الكريم ايضا من اليمن بان
الملفات اليمنيه حقيقه منذ سبتمبر 62 26
سبتمبر 62 وما قبلها اي منذ اسقاط الامامه
وما قبلها كانت اليمن ولا تزال الحقيقه
بؤره توتر وبؤره صراعات مختلفه صحيح بان
اجزاء كثيره من اليمن شهدت ازدهارا وخصوصا
في جنوبها ولكن الواقع يقول بان اليمن لم
يكن في يوم من الايام دوله مستقره مركزيه
واحده بمعنى انا لا اريد ان اقلل من الشان
اليمني ولكن الصوره التي كانت لدى للمشاهد
ربما لدى بعض المتابعين هو ان هناك يمن
واحد حتى في اوجه قوه علي عبد الله صالح
يسيطر الا على المدن الرئيسيه باقي اليمن
للاسف بسبب تضاريسها وتاريخها وصراعاتها
يعني ما اريد ان اقول باختصار هو ان الملف
اليمني ربما يكون احد الملفات التي يجب ان
تتوقف ايران عن التدخل بها عل ذلك يؤدي
الى تمديد هدنه
تجين بمن فيهم
ايضا من اجل الخروج اليمن من
هذا النازف الذي نشعر به جميعا
عاطفا على كلام حضرتك او استكمالا لكلام
حضرتك حضرتك ترى بانه الضاغط او التاثير
الايراني لن يحل ملف اليمن بطريقه كليه
ولكن عميد مجالي هل يمكن القول بان هذا
التقارب السعودي الايراني قادر على الاقل
ان يضع خطه مستقبليه لليمن بان يبدا العمل
على مشروع توحيد هذه البلد ووقف الحرب
فيها خاصه
تسمعني بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لك يا
اختي العزيزه وشكرا لقناه العربيه واشكر
ايضا ضيفك الكريم الذي وضع ايضا النقاط
على الحروف اختي العزيزه كما هو معلوم لدى
شعب من اليمني والعالم
اجمعليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه او التنظيم
جماعه الحوثي الارهابي والذي فعلا تمده
ايران بالاسلحه وكذلك ايضا في الجانب
الاعلامي والاقتصادي طوال هذه الفتره التي
قامت تلك الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه
بالاعتداءات المتواصله على شعبنا اليمني
وبطلاق تلك الصواريخ والقذائف
المستمره على المدنيين والحرب التي قامت
بهذه الكلمه مليشيات الانقلاب الحوثيه
الحقيقه نحن من هنا تحيه لقواتنا المسلحه
البواسل والذي نحن نراهن على هذه القوات
والتي فعلا اجهضت كل التسللات والهجمات
الحوثيه في كل الجبهات القتاليه سواء في
جبهات مارب وتعز ولحق والضلع وغيرها من
المحافظات اما عن سؤالك اختي العزيزه هو
سؤال وجيه وهام نحن نرقب تلك الاحداث
ونشيد بتلك التفاهمات بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وايران برعايه برعايه الصين الشعبيه هذه
المبادره والاتفاقيه والتفاهمات ستسهم
دورا كبيرا وستكون بمثابه قطعه تلك الرئه
التي تتنفس منها الميليشيات الانقلاب
الحوثيه وخاصه بتهريب تلك الاسلحه
والمعدات والخبراء من ايران ان شاء الله
ايران تستجيب لدائات العقل والمنطق ولتلك
الوساطه التي ستسمى
كان هناك دورا واضحا لحكومه اليمنيه من
خلال
الحكومه اليمنيه تؤكد انها ايمانها الصادق
وبالحوار وحل الخلافات بالطرق الدبلوماسيه
والوسائل السلميه وتؤكد على عدم التدخل في
شؤون الدول وهذا سيعكس ايضا دور ايجابي
اختي العزيزه في المدابر الميليشيات
الانقلاب الحوثيه وخاصه تصريحات بعض قاده
الميليشيات اليوم يعني
ان هناك
حضرتك متاخر بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وجمهوريه ايران وحقيقه ان هذه الاتفاقيه
ستكون لها دور كبير ودوره مفعلا وخاصه
لابلاغ خاصه بانه هو لا يسمعني فيمكن ان
يكون هناك تفاعل ساعود لك دكتور سعد ضيف
يامل هو وددت ان اسال انتم تاملون ولكن هل
تتوقعون اطرح هذا السؤال عليك كذلك هل
تتوقع بان ايران ستستجيب اولا لامكانيه ان
يطرح حل حقيقي للملف اليمني وفي خطوه
متقدمه هل الحوت كذلك قادر ان ينخرط في
هذا الاطار
هذا هو حقيقه سؤال المليون كما يقولون في
برامج المسابقات هل يمكن لايران فعلا ان
تقدم ما يعزز بناء ثقه بينها وبين جيرانها
العرب وعلى راسهم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الواقع يقول بان هذا الاتفاق
لاول مره يعقد برعايه صينيه الصينيون ليس
من ذئبهم التدخل في الشؤون الخارجيه للدول
او الداخليه للدول وخصوصا الشرق الاوسط
لكل تعقيداته ومشاكله ومن هنا لا اعتقد
بان الصينيين قد دخلوا في مثل هذا الاتفاق
دون ان يعلموا بان هناك خطوات لابد ان
تتبعه دعينا يعني
اليوم نحن نعيش حاله من على الاقل تخفيف
حده التوتر الذي سبب سياسات الايرانيه في
المنطقه ما يتعلق بالحوثي تذكروا باننا
نتكلم عن 60,000 الى 100 الف ما بين
الحوثيين انصار الله انفسهم وما بين بقايا
جيش علي عبد الله صالح والحرس الجمهوري
لنقل برقم المحافظ بانه 60 الف تحت السلاح
اليوم يقبضون خلونا نقول بمعدل الف دولار
شهريا تتكلم عن 60 مليون دولار من اين
ستاتي بهذه الاموال جماعه صاروا الله
ناهيك عن طبعا صحيح انهم مرهقون الناس
بالضرائب وبحق الخشبه وبحق هذا الجهات
وبحق يعني ما يسمى باللهجه اليمنيه عنده
مختلف الطرق الابتزاز الناس واخذ الاموال
منهم ولكن اذا توقف الدعم الايراني واعلنت
ايراني بانها فعلا لن تتدخل في الشؤون
اليمنيه هذا ربما يخلق
اليمنيه الاخرى ايضا خلونا نكون موضوعين
ترى الاطراف الاخرى ليسوا بمل
ائه ما يمكن وهنا ياتي دور ربما المجتمع
الدولي والمملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
اتت بعد ان يعني
ترجل الرئيس السابق هذه الرئيس الشرعي
لمجلس رئاسه ان يكون هناك ربما حكومه
وطنيه اذا ما اد
فوا لان الرياح لا تجري بما تشتهيه سفنهم
وبانهم عليهم ان يرددوا نفس النشيد مره
اخرى رددي ايتها الدنيا نشيدي اي النشيد
الوطني اليمني ربما في محاوله لاعاده
اللحمه الوطنيه واعاده السلام الى هذا
البلد
ايران تعهدت على الاقل بحسب جورنال تعهدت
بوقف امدادات الحوثي بالاسلحه هذا ما قيل
ولو انه ايران سابقا كان دائما تنفي هذه
المقولات او هذه المواقف وهنا سؤال عميد
مجلي هل يمكن لايران ان فعلا تتعهد وتفي
بكل هذه التعاهدات بوقف امدادات الاسلحه
للحوثي تعتقد ذلك بحسب قراءتك
الحقيقه نحن فعلا نعتمد على الافعال لا
بالاقوال والذي نحن سنلاحظ وخاصه ان هناك
شرط من شروط الاتفاقيه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران خلال مده شهرين
سيكون هناك ايضا قص النبض لحسن النوايا من
قبل ايران في دعمها تلك الميليشيات
الانقلابيه الحوثيه لكن نحن نقول ان كما
هو معلوم سلفا وسابقا سواء من قبل ايران
وكذلك المليشيات الانقلابيه الحوثيه دوما
هي تنقض العهود والمواثيق والهدن طوال
الفتره ابتداء في حربها على الشعب اليمني
والقوات المسلحه منذ العام
2004 حتى هذه اللحظه وكذلك عند بدايه ايضا
الاجهاض الدوله والشرعيه والانقلاب
والعمليات الارهابيه التي قام بها كذلك من
2014 اختي العزيزه نحن اولا نؤمن بالله عز
وجل انه قادر على تغيير الواقع وكذلك نحن
ايضا نشيد بجهود الم العربيه السعوديه
والدول المحبه للسلام في انها تقف ضد
المشروع الايراني التوسعي وكذلك جرائم
وانتهاكات الميليشيات الانقلاب الحوثيه
لكن اجمالا النصر قادم وسيبقى شعبنا
اليمني والشعب العربي وستنتهي تلك
الميليشيات الانقلابيه الحثيه والداعمها
دكتور سعد اذا ما سلمنا جدلا بدقه مجافل
وبتالي بافاء ايران بتعهدتها وبوقف تسليح
الحوثي هل تعتقد كيف سيكون اولا
موقف الحوثي من كل هذه المتغيرات وهل
سيضعفه بالداخل مما سيضع امام امر واقع
يدفع بعمليه سلام تعتقد
طبعا اذا ما تم هذا الامر فان هذا يعني
انقلابا في ثنائيه الدوله الايرانيه نفسها
بمعنى ان الدوله والثوره انتصرت الدوله
فيها على الثوره ايران دولتان او خطاء
خطابين مختلفين دوما لديها
وسياسيتين مختلفتين هناك خطاب الدوله الذي
يتكلم عن قانون الدولي وحسن الجوار
وعلاقات حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل ولكن هناك
الواقع الذي يقول الثوره يجب ان تتمدد وان
تستمر وهو ما نشده في العراق وفي سوريا
وفي لبنان وفي اليمن هل يمكن فعلا ان تبدا
ايران بوقف مثل هذه المساعدات المباشره
عسكريا وماليا لانصار الله في اليمن ما
يقدرون هم يقولون نفس الخطاب الثنائي
للصينيين يعني الصينيون يدركون بانه لا
تستطيع ان تتذاكر علينا اذا كنت تعتقد
بانك يمكن ان تقول مثل هذا الخطاب للعرب
طوال هذه السنوات
العرب يقولون بان هذا الكلام غير حقيقي
فبالنسبه لنا لا يمكن ان نرعى اتفاقا الا
ان تكون واضحا معنا ويكون هناك خطوات
لبناء الثقه في تعزيز هذا الاتفاق واولاها
فعلا وقف دعم الجماعه جماعه صار الله
جماعه الحوثي الذين يرتكبون هذه الفضاءات
ومما يسهل عوده الشرعيه وربما حكومه وطنيه
اتمنى ان ترى النور قريبا لكن باختصار اذا
تم هذا الشيء فهو انقلاب في ايران
الايديولوجيا الى ايران الدوله على فكره
فكره ايران بين الدوله والثوره كان موضوع
نقاشنا بالامس دكتور سعد ربما كنت تابعتنا
بالامس ان كان نعم يسعدنا ذلك دائما
وناقشناه باسهاب وبتفاصيل والاكيد بانه
سيبقى موضوعا للمناقشه في حلقتنا القادمه
اود شكرا لكم على المشاركه في هذا المحور
من النقاش من الك ويت الدكتور سعد بن طفل
العجمي وزير الاعلام الكويتي الاسبق ومن
مارب العميد ركن عبده جوليا المتحدث
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه اليمنيه شكرا
لكما